guys hello I'm such a big fan of yours
thank you thank you that song was
gorgeous oh thank I didn't write it but
I loved singing it yeah it's such a
pretty song right the whole album is
good yeah and Miley is just remarkable
yeah her voice too she's got that really
crazy cool B yeah man she used to she
actually guested it on Two and a Half
Men for a little while and she would
just sit around doing those little vocal
trills uh just you know just offand just
hanging out being doing these amazing
things you're like what that was
literally like working with Ariana on
The Voice we' just be backstage and
she's just constantly like keeping her
like even her really high like whistle
tone she's keeping him in check and I'm
like you're just like sitting there like
I was like what in the world like yeah
people are crazy talented yeah it is a
superpower so wait so you grew up here
now is this like like where I grew up it
looks totally different like it's it
used to be like the countryside now it's
like a metropolis comparatively speaking
what is it like for when you come back
here well New York is always New York uh
um
yeah yeah yeah um but they they uh but
buildings just pop up where you you
least expect them I mean like because I
grew up here you know in the 70s okay
okay that's so it's a little while ago
uh and and it's so different now uh
although interestingly my wife says that
I'm sexier in New York okay um yeah well
if you're dressing like this sir
[Applause]
obiously at your game and no but I hey
it turns out I'm sexier in New
York I was just making a joke CU
everyone's talking about him like turns
out I was a dog in
La anyway I was just kidding I'm totally
kidding um well but the reason why I
realized is because I know where I'm
going I know because I grew up here oh
you're confidence and but like
apparently in every other city of the
world I'm like oh where where is the the
Google Map said there was a thing here
just you know that's me everywhere great
even where I grew up I'm the worst I
can't find
[Music]
[Applause]
anything thank you guys y'all have a
great night going
home